ça lui rendant sa wii ils ont prouvé
ensuite grade comme ça te fait piquer
par une bête non maintenant bataille à
une allergie un problème de peau ou non
pour que je suis tout simplement parce
que j'aime bien
[Musique]
parmi les sujets sur lesquels on me
demande des informations depuis que j'ai
commencé les vidéos il y en a qui
revient particulièrement souvent et il
concerne alors oui c'est vrai il ya ça
mais une des questions qu'on pose le
plus souvent c'est pourquoi on se gratte
et du coup je me suis dit si tout le
monde me pose cette question c'est
peut-être que tout le monde se pose
cette question
et du coup par hasard est ce que ce
serait pas la cause
alors c'est une question toute simple
sauf qu'en fait non pas du tout c est
une question plutôt complexe et comme
souvent si c'est compliqué c'est à cause
des mots qu'on emploie là par exemple on
vit ça me gratte et je me gratte
c'est le même mot qui désigne la cause
et la conséquence le passif et l'actif
l'inconfort et son soulagement
c'est très français ont même malmené les
mots comme ça alors pour rétablir un peu
les choses sinon c'est la chienlit
on ne devrais pas dire ça me gratte on
devrait dire ça me démange et pour être
même encore un petit peu plus précis ce
qui cause les démangeaisons ça s'appelle
le prurit laissez moi prendre une
encyclopédie en double creux sensation
naissance dans la peau et entraînant une
envie de se gratter donc déjà c'est une
sensation
certains estiment que c'est une certaine
forme de douleur mais tout le monde
n'est pas complètement d'accord là
dessus
n'empêche que la douleur et faire
intervenir ce qu'on appelle les no 6
récepteur c'est à dire des terminaisons
nerveuses qui agissent comme des
récepteurs et qui transmettent le
message de la douleur quand elles sont
stimulés on en a un petit peu partout
sur le corps et le prurit lui il serait
déclenchée par l'activation de fruits
récepteur c'est-à-dire de récepteurs
spécifiques de la démangeaison
mais les spécialistes sont pas d'accord
sur le fait de les considérer non pas
comme des mets aussi récepteur bon à
vrai dire j'avoue
on s'emballe en politique nous ce qu'on
veut savoir c'est pourquoi ça démange
bon alors autant vous le dire tout de
suite on laissait pas comme ça marche
mais on a
à
et puis on sait par exemple que ce qui
entre en jeu ça dépend de la cause de la
démangeaison c'est pas forcément une
maladie paulin d'autres causes très
diverses
ça va de la piqûre de moustique à
l'allergie en passant par effectivement
les maladies peau mais aussi d'autres
maladies comme le diabète l'insuffisance
rénale ou certains concerts on sait
aussi que ça implique le système nerveux
et le système immunitaire
par exemple en cas d'allergie ou
d'infections l'organisme repère qui a un
eu libre à évacuer et il envoie ses
hommes de main les globules blancs
certains d'entre eux libère alors des
substances diverses parmi lesquels
l'histamine qui stimule les récepteurs
nerveux de la peau qui sont des bonnes
tout câble donc eu balance l'information
jusqu'au ganglion nerveux sensitif lieu
même valence l'information à la moelle
épinière qui l'a fait remonter jusqu'au
cerveau via le thalamus et le cortex
temporal
et une fois qu'il est au courant le
cerveau il déclenche la sensation de
démangeaison la réaction motrices dans
ces cas là c'est à dire le geste que
notre corps a tendance à faire
spontanément et basse et de se gratter
mais alors pourquoi ça soulage de draper
là encore c'est difficile de se
prononcer à coup sûr mais des études
récentes semblent démontrer que le fait
de se gratter sa déclenché une
inflammation avec elle une certaine
forme de douleur et que pour contrer
cette douleur l'organisme libère de la
sérotonine la sérotonine c'est un
neurotransmetteur qu'on appelle
vulgairement l'hormone du bonheur parce
qu'elle procure une sensation de
bien-être
en l'occurrence elle soulage les
démangeaisons mais dans un premier temps
seulement parce que dans un deuxième
temps est réactive les prairies
récepteur donc elles aggravent les
démangeaisons c'est pour ça que plus on
se gratte plus ingrates
enfin plus ça démange moralité ne ratez
pas en plus au bout d'un moment ça a dû
me la peau et ça arrive de s'infecter
il avait peut-être constaté certaines
personnes équipées de testicules ont
tendance à aller gratter de manière
quasi permanente c'est-à-dire d'une
irritation cutanée bien défaut d'hygiène
par exemple ou d'une ist contractée à la
suite d'un rapport sexuel non protégé
auquel cas il importe de prendre les
mesures idoines
en revanche une fois la cause
physiologique écartée il est bien plus
fréquent qu'il s'agisse d'une sorte de
rituel de vérifications pratiquée par la
personne afin de se rassurer sur la
présence de ses attributs virils
là encore des solutions existent
n'hésitez pas à contacter des
professionnels ok mais alors du coup
vous allez me dire on fait quoi quand ça
démange si on n'a pas de se gratter
vous avez complètement raison de nous
poser la question et vous connaissez
maintenant je suis pas du genre à
laisser les potes dans la merde hein
donc évidemment je vais vous le dire
la réponse c'est ça dépend voilà dtc
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui nord je me
sentais tranquille va pas complètement
ceux subis parce que c'est un peu vrai
la réponse c'est ça dépend voilà dtcc
finit effectivement ça dépend voilà dit
ok non adoption
en fait ça dépend voilà dtc de la cause
de la démangeaison c'est comme d'hab le
plus efficace c'est de traiter la course
donc si c'est un problème de peau d'une
irritation une maladie peau etc
il ya des crèmes ça va de la simple
crème hydratante à la pommade anti
inflammatoires le médecin peut aussi
vous prescrire des antihistaminiques
salir des médicaments qui diminue les
effets de l'histamine dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure puis il ya tout un tas de
traitement en fonction des causes
diverses et variées il ya quand même un
petit truc qui marche souvent pas mal
c'est la fraîcheur autant la chaleur ça
a tendance à aggraver les choses autant
le froid ça apaise souvent les
démangeaisons donc trouvez vous un petit
coin à la fraîche appliquée quelque
chose de froid à l'endroit où ça gratte
ou prenez même un petit pain frais bon
alors sauf dans le cas où le truc qui
grattent c'est une blessure profonde
plaine des chicots là
[Musique]
allez on voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien vous pouvez vraiment y aller là
c'est fini pour de bon ses parents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais vraiment restez pas là je vais
fermer toute façon je vous appelle un
bieber je sais pas